peggy's 16.
does anyone mind if i cut in
wouldn't want to step on anyone's toes
she's stylish she's deadly she's
bayonetta this song from witch talks a
big game and with your divine
intervention she'll slay anyone who
stands in her way why don't i try a more
attentive approach
[Music]
bayonetta's quest will take her to all
sorts of places
and while exploring locales such as this
one mysterious creatures will attack
without warning
time for bayonetta to do what she does
best
use different buttons to execute punches
kicks and fire bayonetta's guns
pull off multiple attacks using
different button combinations or by
pressing them repeatedly
even new players can perform
hair-raising combos with ease
of course there's more to bayonetta than
just attacking dodge incoming attacks at
just the right moment to activate which
time slowing down time for a brief
moment
seize this opportunity to dish out some
serious damage
[Music]
the effects of witch time last longer if
you dodge at the last possible moment so
study your enemies movements carefully
and time those dodges perfectly
[Music]
combine powerful attacks
and bayonetta's unique witch-time
ability
to eliminate threats in style
seems like you're ready for the leash
[Music]
even umbreon witches need a little extra
help when taking on larger-than-life
monsters
time to summon an infernal demon
take control of these demonic darlings
to wallop enemies with mighty moves
bayonetta is exposed to attacks while
summoning so be sure to keep an eye on
her as well
you also want to keep an eye on this
gauge too as summoning demons consumes
bayonetta's magic
knowing when to switch between
commanding infernal demons and
controlling bayonetta is a wicked way to
keep your foes on their toes
infernal demons can even intervene to
bolster combos have your infernal demons
stun an enemy then follow up with one of
bayonetta's exhilarating torture attacks
ouch
[Music]
use the wink slave skill to add a
fiendish finisher at the end of a
or combo up an otherworldly ally to
counter an incoming attack with the
assault slave skill
[Music]
try triggering which time as bayonetta
then switch to your infernal demon to
land some heavy blows
combining bayonetta's abilities with the
might of infernal demons is truly a
match made in heaven
the demonic delights don't end there
by channeling the power of demons bound
to her weapons bayonetta can transform
her appearance
[Music]
and access show-stopping new abilities
for example adding an extra oomph at the
end of your combos or unleash powerful
special attacks like this
each of bayonetta's weapons inhabit
different infernal demon powers
switching weapons in the heat of battle
will not only increase bayonetta's
moveset but also allow more demons to
join the fray
[Music]
the abilities of infernal demons can
also be used while exploring to find new
locations and battles off the beaten
path
no matter what the odds
use bayonetta's stylish moves
and the power of the infernal demons to
come out on top
[Music]
when clearing a chapter you'll receive a
result based on your performance
show him you can slay in style and aim
for the highest score possible
[Music]
you want some too
fine it's bacon time
the mysterious witch in training viola
holds the key to this story
wielding a sword and magical darts the
owner's approach to combat is slightly
different to the titular witch
for example viola can activate witch
time by blocking incoming attacks at the
right time
she can also summon a powerful ally in
the form of the infernal demon bound to
her sword cheshire
while cheshire is summoned the owner
fights bare-handed and without the aid
of witch time while her capricious kitty
goes to town on any enemy it can get its
paws on
switch between viola swordplay and
cheshire supported strikes to bring the
fight to any situation
[Music]
you can change the difficulty settings
at any time to suit you
in addition to the three difficulty
modes shown here there's also a special
accessory for those in need of a helping
hand to stay on top of the action
quip it and you can target foes and
dispatch them with graceful moves by
simply pressing one button
it's a great option for those who only
want to taste the battle and to focus on
enjoying the story
[Music]
can't wait to tap into bayonetta's
naughtier side
even more over-the-top moves and combos
await you each one more beautiful and
brutal than the last
get ready for a devilishly good time
that'll leave you bewitched always
getting in over your head
bayonetta 3 launches october 28th only
on nintendo switch
you